regina se fue en bicicleta a la escuela
recorriendo una distancia de 2 y 14
kilómetros y después fue a casa de su
amiga que se encuentra a una distancia
de 15 octavos kilómetros cuántos
kilómetros recorrió en total aquí lo que
nos están pidiendo es que sumemos los
kilómetros que recorrió regina porque
hay de su casa a la escuela recorrió dos
kilómetros y un cuarto de kilómetro o
sea que tenemos por aquí dos kilómetros
y un cuarto y después recorrido de la
escuela a casa de su amiga un kilómetro
y cinco octavos de kilómetro un
kilómetro y cinco octavos de kilómetro
ahora lo que tenemos aquí con estos
números mixtos es simplemente dos más un
cuarto más uno más cinco octavos y
entonces lo que podemos hacer es sumar
la parte entera o sea dos más uno y
después sumarle lo que nos debe de la
suma de las fracciones podríamos decir
que estamos reacomodando la suma
entonces de la suma de éste
con este lo que nos queda es un 3 y
tenemos que sumarle un cuarto más cinco
octavos
ahora para sumar esto tenemos que
encontrar el denominador común de estas
dos cosas pero pues el 4 divide tanto al
4 como al 8 entonces este 8 es el mínimo
común múltiplo y entonces va a ser el
denominador común entonces aquí lo que
vamos a tener va a ser fracciones con 8
en su denominador ahora de aquí para
pasar de esta fracción a esta fracción
como no le hicimos nada al denominador
tampoco le tenemos que hacer nada el
numerador y para pasar de esta fracción
a esta fracción tuvimos que multiplicar
el denominador por 2 entonces tenemos
que multiplicar el numerador por 2 y 2
por 1 es
sumando lo que nos queda es en octavos 2
+ 5 7 pero a esto todavía le tenemos que
sumar el 3 o sea que tenemos 3 más lo
que nos da de estas sumas de fracciones
que como ya vimos aquí es 7 octavos y
esto escribiéndolo como un número mixto
es tres y siete octavos entonces 2 y un
cuarto más uno y cinco octavos es igual
a tres más uno cuarto más cinco octavos
que es igual a tres más siete octavos y
esa es la cantidad de kilómetros que
recorrió régimen ahora hay algo que yo
quiero que quede muy claro hasta ahorita
hemos hecho puros ejemplos en los que la
suma de estas fracciones terminan siendo
una fracción propia o sea una fracción
donde el numerador es más chico que el
denominador pero no siempre ese es el
caso y ahorita lo que vamos a hacer es
ver un ejemplo donde ese no sea el caso
y vamos a ver qué se hace en esos casos
ahora vamos a sumar 1 y 5 octavos
dos y cuatro octavos okay como siempre
lo primero que hacemos es sumar los
números enteros vamos a sumar este con
este
y nos queda 3 porque recuerden que aquí
lo que tenemos es 15 octavos más dos más
cuatro octavos y que podemos
intercambiar el orden de la suma
entonces sumando los enteros nos queda 3
y nos falta sumar cinco octavos
y cuatro octavos ahora eso es igual a
vamos a seguir sumando el 33 más y estos
octavos como ya tienen denominador común
se suman muy rápido entonces nos queda 5
49 octavos
ahora para escribirlo como un número
mixto uno puede muy rápidamente ponerle
tres y nueve octavos pero si lo quieres
escribir como un número mixto esta
fracción tiene que ser una fracción
propia y esta es una fracción impropia
entonces lo que tenemos que hacer es
reescribir esta fracción impropia como
un entero más una fracción propia y este
8 cabe una vez dentro de este 9 y deja
un 1 de residuo entonces nos queda uno
entero y un octavo y todavía tenemos que
sumar el 3
entonces lo que nos queda son cuatro
enteros y un octavo esta es una buena
forma de escribir como un número mixto
tres más nueve octavos y es el resultado
de uno y cinco octavos más dos y cuatro
octavos